augustus had initiated the third phase
of roman history the empire and he had
provided a model for how it would be
organized Tiberius his successor then
kept things running relatively smoothly
this lecture will trace the fortunes of
the Roman Empire over the next two
centuries and the rulers of this era
will feature both Rome's wisest and most
conscientious Emperor's and several of
its most notorious and really deranged
tyrants the next Emperor to take the
throne was one of the latter a nephew of
Tiberius known by the nickname Caligula
which meant literally Little Boots and
these were actual boots given to him as
a young boy when he had accompanied his
father on military campaigns and he wore
a miniature pair of legionary boots
Caligula was still very very young when
he became Emperor and he rapidly
embarked on a what we might call a reign
of terror and also of profligate
expenditure and just to give you a sense
of the sort of person he was
for entertainment he liked to watch
people being tortured to death whenever
he kissed his wife he would whisper in
her ear you know I could have this
beautiful throat cut any time I please
his favorite saying was let everybody
hate me so long as they fear me and
finally how do you think the ruler of
the known world spent his idle free time
well at least according to one source he
would spend hours every day in front of
a mirror practicing making horrible and
disgusting faces now he did share one
thing in common with the average Roman
he was a fan of horse and chariot racing
and he had a favorite horse which he
named Incitatus it translates literally
to something like speedy Caligula had a
special marble stable built for in
cetanas and on race days he would
stationed troops all around the area
with orders to kill anyone who made
noise just to make sure that Incitatus
got a good night's rest and it was
rumored that Caligula planned to have in
citta toss his horse appointed to the
consulship well after about four years
of these sorts of actions Caligula was
murdered by the commanders of his own
bodyguard who finally just got fed up
with his behavior Caligula though is the
first disastrous result of augustus
decision to base succession on the
principle of heredity but he won't be
the last